es gibt in diesem drama vor der kulisse
von melbourne nur verlierer und die
bittersten verlierer sitzen hier im
abschiebe hotel streng bewacht und ohne
frischluft werden manche schon seit
jahren hier festgehalten
und beklagen maden im nudelgericht und
schimmel im tost wer in australien nicht
willkommen ist bekommt das sehr deutlich
zu spüren aber plötzlich schaute die
ganze welt auf die traurige absteige und
ihren prominenten neuzugang
ich bin einer von 33 männern die hier
eingesperrt sind aber nun sind wir 34 in
diesem gefängnis denn novak djokovic ist
nun auch einer von uns
aber vor allem ist er einer von ihnen
ein serbe und mit denen kann man so
nicht umspringen finden diejenigen
serben deren vorfahren nach australien
kamen als einwanderer hier noch
willkommen waren einige tausend women in
melbourne und einige dutzend
protestierten tagelang vor der migranten
unterkunft sogar mit geistlichem
beistand
[Musik]
er hat kein richtiges fenster er start
nur auf die wand kann sich nicht bewegen
und nicht trainieren
angefeuert von den klage rufen der
mutter empörten sich auch 15.000
kilometer und etliche zeitzonen
westwärts die landsleute in belgrad über
die behandlung ihres eingekerkerten
nationalhelden
überlebensgroß und allgegenwärtig gerade
in diesen stunden der drangsal feiern
die serben ihm mit einer mischung aus
heiligenverehrung und märtyrer mythos
einer von ihnen erfolgreich aber von
aller welt angefeindet das passt in die
zeit und ins serbische
selbstbild
trotz seiner großen erfolge wird
djokovic anscheinend schlechter
behandelt als federer oder nadal
und das passt haargenau in das narrativ
eines für serbien ganz typischen mythos
des helden der gleichzeitig ein opfer
ist
nicht irgendein opfer sondern gleich ein
menschheits opfer maßlos und
größtmöglich so ähnlich halt wie jesus
christus meint der papa
jesus hat so viele leiden ertragen und
opfer gebracht und deshalb lebte nach so
vielen jahrhunderten noch immer unter
uns und das gleiche gilt für novak das
habe ich ihm heute morgen geschrieben
freue dich über deine wunden mein sohn
ein bisschen verwundert ist auch scott
morris und der zweite verlierer der
affäre djokovic
als der siegessichere serbe weltberühmt
und ungeimpft in die mühlen der
einwanderungsbehörden gericht sah der
oft belächelte premierminister die
chance härte zu demonstrieren
regeln sind regeln es gibt keine
sondergenehmigung das ist die linie der
regierung das sind unsere strengen
einreise maßen
schon ganz besonders im hinblick auf die
pandemie
kaum eine demokratische regierung hat
ihrer bevölkerung solche opfer
abverlangt immer wieder strenge lockt da
uns einreiseverbote selbst für
staatsbürger was bis zum mikro auch ganz
gut funktionierte aber nun steigen die
infektionszahlen rasant testcenter sind
überlaufen überall wird personal knapp
und bald sind parlamentswahlen dia
corona frust könnte morris und
gefährlich werden
der richterspruch am montag pro profi
kam der regierung dann extrem gelegen
und ließ seine fans jubilieren vor allem
die serbischen
das habe ich erwartet denn ich glaube an
gott und ich habe immer gewusst wird es
schaffen
die regierung hat ihn ins gefängnis
gesteckt obwohl er nichts falsch gemacht
hat oder doch
rätselhafte pcr-test fehlerhafte angaben
zum reiseweg so ganz unverdächtig war
der ganze vorgang jedenfalls nicht
[Musik]
großartig wie auf dem arena plakat
gepriesen oder doch nur großspurig egal
wie das drama ausgeht steht djokovic als
dritter verlierer fest ungewohnt für den
champion der kein champion der herzen
ist
klar dass pfiffe und buhrufe aber daran
ist er gewöhnt ein publikumsliebling nie
die zufalls umfrage vor ort scheint das
zu bestätigen
wir waren so lange im werk down um uns
zu schützen und er nutzt das für sich
aus er sollte verstehen dass hat keine
ausnahme
der idiot soll er sich doch impfen
lassen solche schwachköpfe bedrohen uns
doch alle mit ihrer jüdischen meinung
ich habe den eindruck er macht sich über
alle schutzmaßnahmen lustig ich finde er
sollte weg gehen
es ist wieder ruhig geworden am
abschiebe hotel in melbourne das
plötzlich weltweit bekannt wurde
djokovic saß 45 tage fest andere warten
seit neun jahren
ich wünschte herr djokovic könnte zu
unserer stimme werden und seine
auftritte nutzen um von seinen
erfahrungen zu berichten
aber darauf warten sie bislang
vergebens
[Musik]